we now return to your regular
programming all right so before we get
into the video I'm just going to let you
guys know there's a lot of popping
noises in my mic so during the video I
kind of cut those out a lot and it can
get to the point to where it's annoying
so just letting you know before we get
into it hello everyone how are you guys
doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today we are here with
another money-making episode so this one
is going to be like my last one with
Loop Hales and tooth halfs of keys if
you guys haven't checked that out that
is a uh that is also a really good one
these types of money-making methods
though are ones that require like a
longer buy time so it's more like
merching rather than just going out and
making money right away but they do
yield the best overall profit per time
actually spent doing things in game so
if you have a lot of money you could
combine this method that I'm about to
show you guys with a method such as my
crystal keys and putting those together
so um if you guys want to check that
video out I made like 230k in 3 minutes
and in this video I'm looking to top
that so today we will be making money
through Skilling which is a little
different it's not actually Skilling
Skilling like you won't get any XP for
this but it does require a skill
requirement to do it so you are in the
act of Skilling I guess but you're not
actually doing it it's much like making
unfinished herbs um into potions or I
guess putting herbs into unfinished
potions so what we will be doing today
is a farming technique so as you guys
can see we're going to go over to trees
now this is where it depends on your
levels so what we'll be doing today is
putting seeds into plant pots and then
watering them and creating them into
saplings so today I am 65 farming so I
will be doing you trees however if you
have 75 there are times where you'll get
more of a margin on magic trees since
less people can do them and gradually it
works its way down um sometimes you may
be able to find big margins on stuff
like oak trees willow trees but
realistically those are very seldomly
bought so you won't be able to sell and
buy those as easily so while the margins
may be there you won't be making as much
money in the end so what we'll be doing
today is I will show you guys my grand
exchange real quick and then we're going
to get right on into it so in the grand
exchange as you guys can see I was able
to buy some U seeds um in total I was
able to buy these for pretty much
64.5 these were 64.8 so I'd imagine the
average is around
6665 Kish so uh we'll go ahead and use
that as our example so I'm going to sell
off something and then see what we can
buy a sapling for all right so here we
are going to go ahead and buy a u
sapling so it says 68k there we see what
we can get it for so
68.1 pretty much um last night you guys
can't see it in the in the exchange but
I was able to buy you saplings for
around 69k so there are definitely more
of a margin there but I guess for the
example of this video we'll be making
about 1.5k per U seed that we end up
putting into a pot so I'm going to go
ahead and do 126 U seeds and see how
long it takes me and then we'll go from
there and see how much money you can
expect to make per hour with these um
just as a little forewarning I did buy
these U seeds overnight however I only
had to offer in for about 70 overnight
and you definitely could have bought way
more if you were looking to do so I
didn't have the cash on me at the time
so it did not happen as most of my uh
money is in
merchesi show you guys how you're going
to want to go about putting these into
um a plant pot so what you're going to
need for this you're going to need
watering cans eight um what I personally
do and I'm going to have to do since I
don't have any filled watering cans is
if you don't if this is your first time
doing these I would recommend if you
plan on doing them a lot in the future
going and buying a ton of watering cans
so what you're going to have to do is I
don't believe you can buy watering cans
pre-filled if you guys can then go ahead
and do that but from my from my
knowledge I do not believe you can buy
water in can's field so what you're
going to have to do is go to any water
source in the game personally I think
one of the ones that is closest to the
bank is the one in catherby and my map
is not loading so I guess we'll just
have to run on over there but you're
going to need to do is first off you're
going to need to use your U seed on the
filled PL pot plant so you can buy these
from the grand exchange or a farmer like
over here and then you're also going to
need a gardening TR so what you're going
to do just use the U seed on the plant
and there it is so now you have a u
seedling so from there you're going to
need to go to a watering Source
personally I use this little house just
north of the bank and go ahead and use
your watering can on the sink so from
there you have eight charges on your can
go ahead and just use on there and then
you'll have a u sapling watered so from
there it does take a couple minutes but
realistically you don't have to spend
that time doing anything you can just
have them banked and eventually over
time they will uh end up filling so
right now I'm just going to do what I
normally do and uh just fill up a ton of
these so if you plan on doing this a lot
just go and run multiple inventories if
you wish and uh it's pretty easy to do
it is a bit tedious though as it doesn't
automatically fill up your entire
inventory which is a little bit of a
downside but in the end it's not all too
time consuming for the amount of money
that you can expect to make per hour so
from there um personally what I like to
do is I don't like to water them at the
same time as I am putting them into the
pots just cuz I don't think it's as
efficient so what you're going to do is
just get a gardening trial um take out
all the seeds you have and then take out
as many pots as you can from there just
put the seeds in the bottom right and
just go to town clicking so I will be
back once I have finished up with these
all right so there we go just a little
bit over a minute later so that took me
about 20 seconds and inventory was what
I was getting and that was about a
little over four about 4 and 1 half
inventory so with 20 seconds in
inventory that took me about 90 seconds
so a minute and a half to do all of
those from there what you're going to
want to do and what I find useful is
just go ahead put these you seedlings
right next to your watering cans eight
withdraw three watering cans and your U
saplings and then continue to do the
same and just water like this so once
you have the entire inventory filled
just rebank and do the same thing all
right all right so there we go about 20
seconds in in inventory again and as you
guys can see the U saplings are starting
to pour in so they do take a little bit
of time as you can see already two of my
inventories that I've watered have
already turned into saplings but there
we go so in total I would say that took
us around 3 minutes as well which is
kind of similar to the last thing that I
did the last guy that the last guide
that I did so that's a little weird so
basically I'm going to go ahead wait for
all these to end up turning into
saplings and then we'll see how much
money we have made in the three minutes
that we have waited all right so I said
earlier in the video that you guys would
be able to make more money if you had a
higher level farming so to go ahead and
try to prove that I'm going to go ahead
and see what you can do with magic seeds
currently so I'm going to go ahead and
buy and sell one and then buy and sell
one of the sapling and see what we can
end up expecting to make off of one of
them all right so now on to Magic
sapling this is the max that you can
expect per hour so if you guys saw that
in the title that's what this is
including so 75 farming for this but as
you guys can see 127k is what you're
able to sell them off for and you buy
them for
123. so that means in total in total
you're making 3.2k every time that you
make a magic sapling which is uh just a
little bit I mean it's actually double
what the U seed is able to do for you so
with the U seed we were able to make
1.5k per one with the magic seed we're
able to make 3.2 so whatever I did here
you can double that and expect that to
make in 3 minutes so let's go ahead the
U sapling should be done and they are
not God damn it God damn it God damn
it God damn it all right so there we go
all of our Ed saplings are done so uh
going to ahead and got to note these I
would imagine all right so as you guys
can see I'm able to sell these on for
8.6 mil and 43k I initially bought these
for 8.4 mil and 64k which means I was
able to make
180k in the span of 3 minutes which is
insane if you ask me I mean
realistically that's over over 3 mil
hour granted you won't be able to do
this constantly but for the time that
you're doing it it is the most efficient
thing to do in the game um at least
better than Zora and stuff like that so
if you then go and apply this to Magic
seeds which is literally more than twice
as much you would be able to make about
400k in the matter of 3 minutes yeah so
I checked it you'd be able to make
46k and the time frame of 3 minutes so
that is absolutely insane and and up to
6 to 7 mil an hour if you were able to
do this hourly so these will sell on um
I'll probably include a clip at the end
of them actually selling because I mean
realistically they're farming supplies
and people will go ahead and buy them
and most people that have the money to
do farming are going to instab buy so
those will be able to sell on so hope
this video is helpful for you guys all
right my roommate just came in but as
you guys can see they're already
starting to sell on but uh hope you guys
have a wonderful day hope this video is
helpful um if you guys enjoyed the video
make sure to leave a like if you guys
want to see more as soon as I go live
and you get the most money out of you
know watching these videos go ahead and
hit that sub button if you guys have
anything you want to tell me go ahead
and comment down below uh PM gam X lamp
or join my clan chat or at least the
clan chat I chill in 07 helpers if you
guys want to stay in touch hit up the
Twitter in the description nonetheless
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace and I gotta go to class God damn
it I'm running late also I know you're
saying you probably didn't sell
off the sapling so here you go
[Music]
d